Robert Downey jr. jokes about which  Captain America Civil War co-star is his  wife's free pass let's see I guess he  gets that she gets a choice on Wednesday  the actor told Howard Stern his free  pass is his Iron Man co-star Gwyneth  Paltrow  I have to protect the one thing I can't  live without that's you hours later et  was with the 51 year old at at Captain  America Civil War fan screening in New  York where he turned the tables and  hilariously revealed which cast made he  choose to be his wife Susan's free pass  you set the tongues you can change our  DJ has been busy traveling the globe  promoting the epic Marvel superhero film  which has already broken free sale  tickets  he says fans are gonna love it look it's  a really right it's a really good movie  so I think  Captain America Civil War is in theaters  May 6